[Musique]
Jérémie Jérémy Assous, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de votre métier
avocat, pénaliste au barreau de Paris.
Présentez-vous succintement.
Je suis avocat. Je dirais pas que
je suis pénaliste puisque je fais aussi
beaucoup de droits du travail, beaucoup
de contentieux commerciaux, euh beaucoup
de propriétés intellectuelles et du
droit de la presse. Mais souvent, on
m'associe,
on me donne, on me colle l'étiquette
pénaliste parce qu'il y a eu quelques
dossiers notamment en droit pénal euh
que j'ai traité et qui ont été assez
médiatisés. Et donc on pense que mon
activité c'est essentiellement du droit
pénal mais c'est ça représente 20 %.
Bon avant de commencer à faire saigner
les oreilles de nos auditeurs et nos
téléspectateurs,
l'affaire Tarnac,
on en est où ? 10 ans de procès. Est-ce
que on peut nous faire un petit résumé
en profondeur ?
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
euh
il y a une décision de justice qui a été
rendu
quand
le mois d'avril, ça a été une relaxe
générale que du général.
Mais ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant, c'est que cette décision
est définitive.
Alors qu'est-ce que c'était l'affaire
Tarnac ? L'affaire Tarnac, c'est une
affaire qui commence en judiciairement
en 2008
où on reproche un certain nombre de
personnes, ce qu'on appelle le groupe de
Tarnac, d'avoir non seulement commis des
actes de dégradation sur les voies de
chemin de fer, notamment les lignes à
grande vitesse, mais on a considéré que
c'était des attentats, donc c'est ça
relevait de la législation
antiterroriste. tentative d'assassinat ?
Non, non, non, non.
le Non non, il y a jamais eu dès le
début, dès le premier jour, dès les
premières heures, tout le monde a été
d'accord pour dire qu'il n'y avait aucun
risque euh que le le fait de poser des
fer à béton ne pouvait pas provoquer euh
de euh ne pouvait pas provoquer de
risque pour les voyageurs ou pour les
passagers du train.
D'autant que c'est une méthode la pause
de fer à béton, c'est une méthode qui a
été utilisée des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois mais en Allemagne. les
activistes allemands qui sont à
l'origine de ces méthodes qui a
fait ses preuves
puisque aujourd'hui par exemple et ceux
dès 2004
le train castor puisque c'était les
activistes écologistes allemands qui
posaient des fer à béton sur les
caténaires pour empêcher le passage du
train et pour bloquer le passage du
train. Pourquoi ? parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que ça ne ça ne fait pas
arrêter euh le train, le train continue
de passer, ça abîme juste euh ça ça
déchire un ou deux pendules, ce qui est
ou 10 pendules, c'est les conséquences
matérielles sont assez faibles. Vous
avez par exemple pour l'affaire dite de
Tarnac euh dans euh pour le fer à béton
qui était posé en Saarn, les dégâts
étaient inférieurs à 12000 €. Mais
pourquoi c'est extrêmement intelligent
de le faire, de le poser, c'est que si
vous le posez à des endroits
stratégiques, les conséquences elles
sont inéluctables. Vous êtes obligé pour
enlever le fer à béton de couper le
courant dans les deux sens. Donc euh si
c'est euh au niveau de la voie ferrée,
donc si c'est un point kilométrique
stratégique, inéluctablement, vous allez
devoir couper le courant et donc les
trains ne pourront plus circuler et donc
vous allez générer des retards qui vont
être considérables. Et ce qui s'est
passé dans la nuit du 7 au 8 novembre
euh 2008, c'est qu'il y a eu quatre fer
à béton qui ont été posés à des endroits
bien précis, bien stratégiques. et ça
généré le fait de les retirer, pas le
fait de les poser, mais le fait de les
retirer a généré des centaines de
milliers d'heures de retard cumulé. Et
donc pourquoi c'est vraiment euh la la
l'affaire de de Tarnac est euh très
intéressante, c'est que euh
le les services euh secrets puisqueà
l'époque c'était DCRI, le parquet
antiterroriste,
le ministre à l'époque c'était madame
Alomarie ainsi que les juges
d'instruction
donc antiteroristes avaient fait de
grandes déclarations disant qu'ils
avaient arrêté
euh le en moins de 72 he les
responsables de la pause des fer à béton
qui avait eu lieu donc dans la nuit du 7
au 8 novembre et que c'était des jeunes
personnes issues
de enfin qui qui qui qui vivait en
communauté en Corè plus exactement à
Tarnac et c'était la base arrière de
d'une lutte armée que c'était l'ennemi
de l'intérieur. ailleur enfin tout le
champ lexical d'action directe tout le
champ lexical vraiment extrêmement
dangereux où on pensait en tout cas
c'est ce que a soutenu la ministre et le
procureur de la République espèce
monsieur Marin en disant que ils avaient
arrêté
les personnes les plus dangereuses
en France
donc Julien Coupa et
Julien Coupa et 8 autres personnes, 9
autres personnes, 15 autres personnes.
Il y a eu beaucoup d'arrestations euh
mais euh ça a été symbolisé vraiment par
euh Julien Coupa euh puisque on lui
attribuait aussi euh le livre
L'insurrection qui vient
invisible. Voilà le fameux on on pensait
que et euh l'accusation soutenait que
Julien Coupa était l'auteur de
l'insurrection qui vient et c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire judiciaire
contemporaine qu'un livre a été alors
qu'il était autorisé, il a rien
d'illégal a été versé intégralement dans
le dossier et que ce livre a été
instrumentalisé, exploité par
l'accusation, donc que ça soit le
parquet ou l'instruction pour démontrer
le bien fondé
des poursuites. Alors, on va rentrer un
peu plus en profondeur dans le dossier
puis on va switcher sur un autre sujet.
Donc, pour résumer trivialement, l'État
avec ses pouvoirs régaliens s'attaque à
ce qu'il considère comme une mouvance
d'ultra gauche ou d'extrême gauche selon
la le qualificatif.
L'enquête a été menée comment et est-ce
que cette enquête vous a servi pour
décharger vos clients ? ce qui a été
enfin faut faut il y a plusieurs étapes
si on veut comprendre le dossier.
Vous avez une étape service secret donc
ce que service de renseignement donc
c'est la fameuse DCI enfin au début
c'était les renseignements généraux puis
après ça a été la DCRI puis après vous
avez l'enquête police judiciaire
puisqueil y a une enquête préliminaire
qui est ouverte.
Ce qui est vraiment particulier dans le
dossier de Tarnac, c'est que tous les
éléments qui ont été présentés comme à
charge, comme étant les éléments à
charge, tant au prévenu que à la presse
se sont révélés être des éléments à
décharge.
Comment ?
Alors voilà,
il y a eu des arrestations qui se sont
faites sous l'œil des caméras. Il y a eu
une mise en scène qui est qui a été
organisée. Donc le fameux 11 novembre,
il 150 policiers, des hélicoptères,
France 3 invité, toutes les images
vendues données aux différents JT. Euh
les médias le lendemain euh embrayent
mais complètement et reprennent mot à
mot sans aucune vérification toutes les
accusations policières et la version
policière. C'est la fameuse une de
libération, l'ultra gauche des rails. Et
ce qui est très intéressant, c'est que
vous avez des arrestations, c'est
spectaculaire. Vous avez des placements
à garde à vue. Vous avez une conférence
de presse organisée par Michel Alomari
qui reprend les éléments de langage de
la police en disant qu'ils ont mis un
terme, ils ont arrêté l'ennemi de
l'intérieur, les gens extrêmement
dangereux qui allaient passer à la lutte
armée, pour qui la vie humaine a
beaucoup moins d'importance que les
idées politiques. Puis il y a le 3è jour
et les journalistes sont très frayants.
Il y a une concurrence entre il faut
absolument qu'ils aient des
informations. Est-ce qu'il y a des aveux
? Non. Est-ce que les gardes à les
perquisitions puisqu'il y en a eu des
dizaines dans des dizaines d'endroits,
ont conduit à la découverte d'éléments
les impliquants ? Il y a rien.
Alors, c'est quoi ? C'est de
l'opportunisme ? C'est une enquête
baclée ? C'est des incompétents ou c'est
ou c'est des fonctionnaires qui avaient
envie de de monter ?
10 ans avec avec Durcul, je pense qu'ils
étaient ils sont assez mauvais. Je crois
que c'est tout simplement
beaucoup d'incompétences
euh de la part des services
et euh de une grosse pression euh de la
part subie par leur hiérarchie. Je pas
c'est pas le petit chef hein, c'est
vraiment leur chef et une panique au
niveau du ministère. aucun effet
d'opportunisme politique sur il faut
trouver un coupable ce
je pense mais mais non mais ça ça on
peut pas reprocher à Michel Liarie
d'avoir mis la pression sur ses services
euh quand vous avez euh la France qui
est bloquée. Je vous rappelle quand même
que euh le 8 novembre 2008 c'est les
vacances de la Toussin. C'est un énorme
weekend et toutes les gares sont
fermées. Il y a un coup, c'est
catastrophique avec des déclarations qui
émanent de la direction de la SNCF qui
dans un premier temps, ce que je disais
en préambule, ils ont vu la pause des
fers à béton, les endroits où ces
derniers ont été posés, ils se sont dit
ce sont des gens de chez nous, ce sont
des spécialistes.
Et donc au début, ils avaient pensé que
c'était des membres de la SNCF et que
c'était du sabotage. Et donc il y a eu
une grosse panique et il est normal que
le ministre il se passera exactement la
même chose aujourd'hui et depuis 10 ans,
il se passe systématiquement la même
chose quand il y a un événement qui est
très important mais une énorme pression.
Après
euh je pense que euh ils ont agi dans la
précipitation et il y avait euh une
équipe des membres des euh DSI et de la
police judiciaire qui surveillait euh
Julien Coupa et certains de ses amis et
ils se sont dit "Bon bah nous on peut
vous livrer clé en main euh
les responsables de cela alors qu'ils
avaient aucun élément. Le seul élément
qu'ils avaient à charge, c'était
soi-disant une filature
qui aurait été faite dans la journée du
euh qui aurait commencé euh le 7
novembre au matin et qui serait terminé
le 8 novembre à euh 5h30 du matin où les
policiers affirment avoir vu la voiture
de Julien Coupa près d'une voie de
chemin de fer euh dans lequel un fer à
béton a été posé. Mais il ne voit pas
Julien Coupa sortir ou rentrer de le
véhicule. Il ne voit personne poser le
faire un béton. ne voit pas euh le
moment où il le pose, où euh il se
sépare, où il il pourrait éventuellement
jeter se séparer euh de la perche qui
aurait permis la pose d'un fer béton
parce que je rappelle quand même que les
caténées, ils sont à 5 m de hauteur.
Donc il voit rien. Et c'est cet élément
qui est présenté comme un élément à
charge et qui justifie les arrestations
et les préquisitions. cette fameuse
filature, c'est ce fameux procès verbal
qu'on a appelé le procès verbal des 104
puisque c'était la côte des 104. Donc il
y a ces arrestation
et ils espèrent que les perquisitions
vont permettre de toute façon
alors j'ouvre une parenthèse. Cette
fameuse filature, c'est une filature
rêvée, c'est une filature incompétente
ou c'est un faux témoignage d'un
fonctionnaire ?
On avait porté plainte pour faux.
Cette procédure a abouti à un non lieu.
Donc juridiquement, ce n'est pas un
faux.
Il n'empêche euh que euh
ce procès verbal contient tellement de
contradictions avec la réalité
qu'il est inconciliable avec cette
dernière. Après, vous en détisez ce que
vous voulez, mais les juges
d'instruction avaient tout fait pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de reconstitution,
qu'on ne puisse pas confronter les
informations contenues dans le procès
verbal avec la réalité notamment via un
transport sur les lieux. Ils avaient
systématiquement refusé et lorsqu'ils
l'ont fait, c'était un simulac une farce
qu'on a dénoncé. C'était même c'était
tellement grottesse que ça était assez
drôle. Euh lorsque nous sommes euh
premier jour d'audience du procès, nous
avons demandé un transport sur les
lieux. Le tribunal a fait droit à cette
demande et à partir et ça a été un
transport qui a été organisé
normalement. C'était flagrant. C'estàd
que tout ce que les policiers disaient
avoir vu nous avocat, juge, procureur,
témoin et prévenu, bah on l'a pas vu. Et
tout ce qu'il disait ne pas avoir vu, on
le voyait.
Vous y étiez pas. Est-ce que sinon vous
auriez vu la même chose que nous ?
C'était exactement les mêmes conditions
météorologiques, physique dans la nuit.
Donc
ça ne correspond à rien. Donc moi
personnellement, j'ai déjà dit
publiquement ce que je pensais de ce
procès verbal.
De toute façon, aujourd'hui, on a une
décision de justice qui rappelle que ce
procès verbal ne peut absolument pas
constitué et être considéré comme un
élément à charge et donc une preuve qui
pourrait conduire à une condamnation de
Julien Coupa. Mais au contraire que
c'est un élément à décharge puisque tous
les moments clés, les moments forts pour
reprendre un terme policier euh bah
il ne figure pas dans le procès verbal.
On va on va ouvrir une autre une autre
parenthèse. Euh
est-ce que à votre avis c'est un dossier
politique, hautement politique et est-ce
que c'est une une criminalisation des
luttes sociales ? Vous avez vous avez lu
l'insurrection qui vient
h
à votre avis, est-ce que le pouvoir
politique
est exent ? Est-ce que le pouvoir
politique est aux abois ?
Et est-ce que il se cherche des
coupables et surtout des coupables des
ennemis intérieurs ? Non non non non,
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe. Faut se remettre dans le
contexte. On est en 2008, on est à des
années lumière de la Fermiera
euh de Charlie Hebda et du 13 novembre.
D'après ce qui se dit, ça a jamais été
infirmé. C'est Alain Boer, donc qui vit
de
de la sécurité, de ces fameux conseils
en matière de sécurité qui tombe sur une
insurrection qui vient et se dit "C'est
quelque chose, c'est un signal faible,
il se passe quelque chose, euh faut
s'intéresser pour reprendre ces mots."
Je n'ai jamais lu euh quelque chose
d'ussi intelligent qui émanerait d'ultra
gauche depuis les années 70. et c'est
les prémisses euh d'action directe
puisque Action Directe avait commencé
par ce type de taxe, ce type
d'expression et donc il en achète 40
exemplaires. C'est vrai puisque on a
parce que c'est la fabrique qui édite le
livre et on a il y a une trace d'une
commande de 40 exemplaires à Alain Boer
et il passe son temps d'après ce qu'il
dit à le distribuer à des politiques, à
des journalistes pour dire "Regardez
intéressez-vous à ça, il se passe c'est
vraiment intéressant."
Ça c'est la version euh d'Alain Boer et
c'est ce qui aurait déclenché un peu
l'enquête
à l'encontre de Julien Coupa et certains
de ses amis.
Après la version officielle, c'est
Julien Coupa traverse la frontière
américaine
à pied, enfin du Canada aux États-Unis à
pied. Lorsqu'il revient,
il y a ses bagages qu'il avait confié à
un ami sont contrôlés. Il demande à qui
appartiennent ces bagages. Ils
comprennent que c'est quelqu'un et que
c'est Julien Coupa qui a traversé la
frontière à pied. Ils font une copie de
tout ce qu'il y a dans son sac. Euh il
le restituait à Julien Coupa. Ce dernier
rentre à Paris tout à fait normalement.
Mais euh les services américains euh
informe leurs homologues euh français
pour dire voilà il y a euh quelqu'un euh
qui a traversé euh notre frontière euh
de manière illégale euh et il a assisté
à une réunion euh totalement clandestine
d'anarchistes à New York, une réunion
internationale très insurrectionnelle et
cetera et cetera. Tout ça cette réunion
n'a jamais existé. C'était juste une
réunion entre copains, mais euh ils
étaient infiltrés par euh un indicateur
enfin par un policier euh anglais euh
donc Marc Kennedy euh qui lui euh n'a eu
de cesse de monter un très grand nombre
de dossiers, de dénoncer un très grand
nombre de crimes imaginaires ou
justement de groupuscules
insurrectionnel qui n'existait pas pour
continuer mais il l'a reconnu hein pour
continuer à vivre cette espèce de double
vie avec tous les avantages qu'elle
procure, beaucoup d'argent,
tous les passes droits possibles et
imaginables,
les décorations et cetera.
Donc l'enquête, elle commence
officiellement comme ça et je pense que
c'est plus la réalité que l'intervention
d'Alain Boer qui à mon avis a beaucoup
moins de pouvoir qu'on lui prête et
qu'il s'attribue.
Après moi je crois que c'est culturel.
Vous êtes en 2008, il y a la fusion des
renseignements généraux avec la DST, sa
fameuse DCI, le fameux FBI à la
française voulu par Nicolas Nicolas
Sarkozi.
Donc il y a des rivalités mais je pense
pas que dans un premier temps ça soit le
fruit d'une rivalité ou d'un dérapage ou
d'un piège. La faire de Tarnac. Je crois
tout simplement que euh les services euh
français euh avaient pour habitude et
pour spécialité euh la surveillance de
deux catégories de personnes euh enfin
de de mouvements. Euh c'est euh
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche.
Les corps c'est les basques.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Mais politiquement
j'entends les corps et les basques.
C'est c'est différent parce que c'est
politique mais c'est plus un mouvement
indépendantiste euh et pour d'autres
raisons. Je parle niveau
insurrectionnel, si on parle
d'insurrection, si on parle de
révolutionnaire, j'entends
et je crois vraiment euh qu'il euh il
savait faire que cela et donc c'est une
espèce d'habitude. Donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Ben, je vais surveiller euh les
gens d'extrême droite ou je vais
surveiller les gens d'extrême gauche qui
sont surveillé quasiment
de manière quasiment permanente. On l'a
vu avec l'affaire Mérique, donc Clément
Mic, le jeune qui est mort à la suite
d'une bagarre avec des gens d'extrême
droite. Ils étaient tous sur écoute,
c'est que ils ont été interpellés très
rapidement parce que on n'a pas mis sur
écoute à la suite de l'incident enfin de
de la mort tragique de Clément Amérique,
c'est qu'ils l'étaient déjà, ils le sont
en permanence. Et donc moi, je pense que
il ils surveillent les gens euh
ce qu'il considèrent comme étant des
acteurs ou les dirigeants du mouvement
de l'extrême gauche en permanence. Et
donc lorsque il y a les événements du 7
au 8 novembre, lorsqu'il y a il y a
incident du 7 au 8 novembre, bah on leur
demande
qu'est-ce que vous avez puisque c'est ce
qui se passe puisque là Michel Alumari a
expliqué qu'elle avait des réunions tous
les jeudis soirs sur l'antiterrorisme et
il fallait systématiquement que les
différents chefs de service amènent des
éléments nouveaux. Et donc il y en a il
disent bah voilà, moi je surveille les
basques, moi je surveille les corses,
moi je surveille les anarchistes, moi je
surveille euh les skinet et donc il
devait lui apporter euh régulièrement de
nouveaux éléments. Quand il y a eu les
incidents, il y a quelqu'un qui s'est
proposé qui a dit voilà moi je pense que
euh c'est euh le groupe dit tarnac que
nous surveillons depuis de nombreuses
semaines, depuis de nombreux voix.
Qui c'est qui a proposé ça ? Vous avez
des noms ? tout en ton tout en
respectant pas de diffamation que
non non non mais j'ai j'ai pas de nom en
particulier mais euh je vous invite à
lire l'excellent livre de du Freine
Tarnac magasin général
il suffit de savoir qui était
l'interlocuteur d'Ali Marie sur cette
questionlà c'est pas le commissaire
c'est le DRPP c'est ça non
il y a DRPP mais il y a aussi la DCRI
enfin l'information est remonté très
vite.
Est-ce que vous avez eu déjà des
interactions avec des gens du
renseignement intérieur ? Est-ce que
vous en connaissez dans le cadre privé
ou dans le cadre professionnel ? Est-ce
que vous avez discuté avec ces hommes ou
ces femmes ?
Oui, je pense. Mais ouis, enfin euh ça
m'est arrivé, ça m'est arrivé. Il ils
vous disent pas qu'ils sont membres.
Vous le comprenez assez rapidement.
Ouais.
Question d'internet. Sa justile a-t-elle
conclu que ce sont des gens accusés à
tort ou qu'il n'y avait pas assez de
preuvam ?
Euh, elle est allé beaucoup plus loin la
justice. Et c'est une très bonne
question, c'est que le tribunal a
considéré que le groupe de Tarnac était
une fiction.
Donc c'est ce que nous avons toujours
soutenu, c'est-à-dire que c'était
une invention policière.
Euh donc
le ils ont été totalement blanchis.
C'est pas faute de preuve, c'est euh
vous il y a aucune raison, il y a rien
dans le dossier qui permet non seulement
de vous condamner mais même de vous
poursuivre. Est-ce que ça veut dire que
des services de renseignement peuvent
mettre plus de 40 jours en prison des
innocents sur simple fait de d'amener un
os à son à son chef de hiérarchie pour
justifier son salaire ?
Alors déjà, Julien Coupa, il a passé
plus de 180 jours en prison et Julien
Coupa euh
n'a retrouvé la liberté que grâce à ses
soutiens euh grâce au mouvement qui a
été
lié à son comité de soutien, un très
grand nombre de journalistes à une
mobilisation très forte. Mais ce qui est
intéressant
euh c'est pourquoi Julien Coupa est
resté si longtemps en prison et pourquoi
la chambre de l'instruction a
systématiquement ainsi que le juge
d'instruction refusé sa remise en
liberté alors qu'il y avait un juge de
la liberté de la détention qui lui
ordonnait sa remise en liberté. Euh et
c'est ça qui est vraiment euh
passionnant, c'est que euh la chambre
d'instruction refusait l'armisant
liberté Julien Coupa au motif qu'il
existait ce fameux procès verbal de
filature qui après analyse s'est révélé
être un élément comme étant à décharge.
Mais encore fallait-il l'analyser, il
fallait le confronter à la réalité. Ce
que les juges d'instruction ne voulaient
pas faire durant toute l'instruction.
Mais un deuxième élément que j'ai euh
pas évoqué parce que j'ai été un peu
j'étais coupé dans mon dans dans ma
démonstration.
Deuxième élément, c'était du fait d'un
témoignage euh
d'une personne qui a témoigné sous le
régime du témoin anonyme. Attention,
c'est pas un témoin anonyme, c'est une
personne dont on cache l'identité parce
que la révélée pourrait mettre en danger
son intégrité physique. C'est le fameux
témoin T42 du dossier qui n'est autre
que Jean-Hug Bourgeois.
Euh ce qui est
Vous avez le droit de citer son nom ?
J'ai j'ai le droit de citer son nom
puisque aujourd'hui nous le savons même
si juridiquement on ne peut pas révéler
l'identité d'un témoin qui bénéficie de
ce statut sous peine de poursuite et la
sanction c'est 50 de prison. Donc c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement sérieux et
ce régime n'existe que pour protéger les
personnes qui peuvent avoir accès à
certaines informations et qui peuvent
collaborer avec la justice mais euh qui
sont très proches finalement des
personnes mais qu'on ne peut pas
soupçonner d'avoir commis la moindre
infraction.
Mais ce qui est terrible dans l'affaire
Tarnac à l'encontre de Julien Coupa,
c'est que ce témoin anonyme fait une
déposition le dernier jour des gardes à
vue. Donc je reviens par rapport à ce
que je disais initialement. Vous avez un
procès verbal de filature où les
policiers disent avoir vu la voiture
près de la voie ferrée mais c'est tout.
Il ne voit rien. Ils disent pas qu'ils
l'ont quitté des yeux et pourtant ils
disent pas non plus qu'ils ont vu Julien
Coua en sortir et poser le fer béton et
revenir et repartir. Donc finalement le
fait qu'elle soit surveillée par 18
fonctionnaires de police et que aucun
des 18 fonctionnaires de police n'ait vu
Julien Coupa sur les voies ferrées,
poser quoi que ce soit devient un
élément à décharge. Et donc c'est un
aiment très important, c'est que le
procès verbal des 104 où on voit le
véhicule près la voiture mine de fer
mais puisqu'on ne voit pas personne en
sortir bah et puisqu'on considère qu'il
est conduit par Julien Coupa, bah dans
ces cas-là Julien Coupa n'a pas pu poser
le fer béton puisqu'il est suivi de 11h
le matin le 7 novembre jusqu'à 6h du
matin le 8 novembre. Or le fer à béton
n'a pu être posé qu'entre 22h8
et 5h11. c'estàd la période durant
laquelle il y a aucun train qui passe.
Donc on a un élément à décharge. Mais il
y a un deuxième élément c'est que vous
avez donc rien il ne ressort rien des
perquisitions. Il ne ressort rien des
auditions alors que 15 personnes sont
placées en garde à vue. Aucun
fait des dépositions qui peuvent être
considérées comme à charge contre Julien
CAS. Donc il y a pas assez pour une mise
en examen puisque il faut quand même
rappeler
aux internautes que pour être placé en
garde des vue, il faut des soupçons.
Donc là, vous avez un procès verbal,
vous avez des filatures, vous avez une
enquête préliminaire qui a duré très
longtemps. Ça suffit pour placer les
gens en garde à vue. Vous savez un
soupçon, c'est très très large. On l'a
vu encore le 1er mai dernier, il 194
personnes qui ont été interpellé. Voilà.
Euh pour rien. Donc vous avez des
soupçons. Par contre pour être mis en
examen, il faut des indices graves et ou
concordants.
La différence entre un soupçon et un
indice, elle est énorme.
Or, il y a pas assez
pour les mettre en examen. Mais nous
sommes le vendredi 14 novembre. La
ministre s'est exprimée le 12 novembre.
On a fait sa conférence de press en
disant "Nous avons les coupables
comme par extraordinaire.
Le vendredi matin
à midi fin de matinée, il y a ce fameux
témoin T42 qui dit "Je connais très bien
Julien Coupa, je connais très bien le
groupe de Tarnac. Julien Coupa est un
gourou. Julien Coupa est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement dangereux
pour qui la vie humaine a beaucoup moins
d'importance que les idées politiques et
c'est
le chef d'un groupe armé. Voilà grande
ligne de la déposition du témoin 42. Et
là comme c'est un témoignage,
c'est très fort témoignage validé par le
juge de la liberté de la détention
puisque pour bénéficier
de l'anonymat, c'est pas le procureur
qui peut le faire puisque le procureur
quand même c'est l'accusateur. Il faut
que ça soit un juge indépendant, donc un
juge du siège. Donc c'est le JLD et seul
le JLD à l'identité de cette personne là
valide le recours à ce procédé.
Et là, comme par magie,
vous avez le témoignage constitue un
indice mais indice extrêmement solide,
très violent qui justifie
non seulement
une mise en examen, donc tout le monde
est mis en examen le vendredi soir, mais
également
les réquisitions et la les réquisitions
de placement de détention et la saisine
du juge de la liberté de la détention
par le les juges d'instruction et le
placement de détenstion.
Or, il s'est avéré que ce témoignage est
totalement faux.
Et
avant de démontrer qu'il était
totalement faux, il y a des journalistes
qui ont fait très correctement leur
travail et qui ont compris très
rapidement parce qu'ils avaient laissé
un très grand nombre d'indices que ces
témoignages étaient le témoignage de
Jean-Hourgeois. Et Jean-Hourgeois est
pas quelqu'un de totalement inconnu.
Jean-Uc Bourgeois est quelqu'un qui euh
est même très connu aujourd'hui
puisqu'il a bénéficier d'un traitement
médiatique très important, notamment il
a une page dans le monde, plusieurs
pages dans la libération puisque il
avait témoigné en disant je suis victime
d'une véritable cabale et de je vis un
grand danger. Moi paysan.
Je me suis installé en Corè, j'ai voulu
exploiter une exploitation agricole bio.
J'avais mes chèvres et un matin toutes
mes chèvres avaient été tuées.
De plus, j'ai reçu des lettres de
menaces extrêmement violentes dont une
et je le cite parce que vous allez
comprendre l'impordance extrêmement
grave puisque il avait une jeune fille
de 12 ans de mémoire et dans cette
lettre il était écrit "On va faire de ta
fille une femme."
Bien évidemment là la police est saisie.
Enfinie, il y a une enquête, c'est très
grave, le monde a investi disant "Mais
comment se fait-il ?" Voilà, on peut
même plus cultiver, c'est parce que il
fait du bio, parce que il lutte contre
les grands producteurs ou les les
grandes entreprises, céréalièr et cetera
puisque a tout un faut faut j'invite vos
internautes à reprendre les articles sur
Jean Bourgeois. C'est un héros
Bourgeois, c'est un résistant, c'est
comme ça qu'il est présenté. une victime
du système.
Or,
il s'est avéré que tout ça c'était faux.
Ses chefs, c'est lui qui les a tué. Il y
a des expertises graphologiques
qui concluent que les lettres c'est lui
qui les a écrites.
Les propres lettres de Manass, la
fameuse lettre que je viens de vous
citer.
C'est un dangereux mythomane.
Et non, non, mais pourquoi pourquoi
c'est très important ? Excusez-moi de
couper, c'est un peu long mais faut
vraiment comprendre.
Là, vous avez un journaliste
qui
annonce
son nom.
Euh, ça c'est dans le livre, je je cite
pas son nom, mais vous allez comprendre
parce qu'il y a deux journalistes qui
l'ont fait qui annoncent qui va
notamment au service qui va révéler
l'identité
de Jean-Huc Bourgeois. Il va révéler à
tout le monde que T42 c'est Jean
Bourgeois. Vous voyez bien que ça change
tout pour nous. Avocat de la défense, ça
change tout. Si on vous dit le témoin
anonyme c'est Jean-Luc Bourgeois, on dit
il a aucune crédibilité le témoin
anonyme. Et donc nous allons
immédiatement demander une confrontation
avec Jean-Hug Bourgeois et puis euh voir
pourquoi vous avez fait ce type de
déclaration. Est-ce que c'est un lien
avec vos affaires ? Est-ce que c'est un
lien avec l'enquête ? Est-ce que vous
espérez quelque chose ? Au passage, je
suis sûr que ça n'a aucun lien. Toutes
les procédures de dénonciation de crime
imaginaire ont été annulées pour un vise
de procédure, enfin pour un défaut
d'indice grave et concordant. Donc
monsieur Bourgeois a bénéficié d'une
annulation et tant mieux pour lui. Mais
donc toutes les poursuites à son
encontre ont été annulées, pas
abandonné, annulé.
À partir du moment où si nous avions eu
cette information, le dossier Tarnac qui
se serait terminé en décembre 2009
et Julien Coupa, il aurait pas fait 6
mois de prison. Mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
que les policiers, le parquet et le juge
d'instruction ont l'excellente idée pour
bloquer
cette information
de mettre en place un véritable
stratagème.
C'est votre interprétation ?
Non non non non, c'est l'interprétation
du tribunal. C'est dans le jugement.
J'invite le jugement est public he vous
pouvez le lire et je vous l'ai
communiqué et donc je parle sous votre
contrôle et je vous invite à le publier
d'ailleurs le jugement puisque vous
l'avez
on se fait l'avoqué du diable. Non, non,
mais vous faites bien, vous faites bien.
Il y a une mise en place d'un véritable
stratagème qui consiste à entendre
Jean-Hug Bourgeois sous son identité.
Jean-Hug Bourgeois a entendu le 14
novembre sous le statut de témoin
anonyme et il a entendu le 11 décembre
sous son identité.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il dit sous son identité
? Julien Coupa, oui, je le connais peu.
C'est vraiment un brave garçon très
pacifique, très doux, très dans les
livres.
C'est le groupe de Tarnac, enfin ils
habitent à Tarnac, sont très gentils. Je
les ai vu une fois, on s'est échangé un
bou et on a discuté. Non, je pense
absolument pas que ce soit des gens
violents et absolument pas coupant. Et
donc là, nous nous retrouvons dans une
situation
où en décembre 2008, la défense de Coua
se dit "Mais si Bourge
si T42 c'est bourgeois, comment il a pu
être entendu sous son identité C'est
impossible parce que c'est trop déloyal
et comme c'est totalement
contradictoire, on ne peut pas puisque
le parquet le saurait et le parquet ne
peut pas
avoir participé à ce stratagème.
Et donc pendant de nombreux mois, cet
argument doit être abandonné
et les mis en veille. Et Julien n'y
croit pas. Il dit ça peut être que euh
Jean-Hug Bourgeois
à chaque fois qu'il demande sa remise en
liberté, on lui oppose le D104 donc le
procès fature mais surtout le témoignage
de T42.
Il est remis en liberté en mai. D'accord
mai 2009.
Il nous désigne nous en septembre 2009
avec Thierry Lévi. Donc on est désigné
change d'avocat, c'est Thierry Lévi et
moi qui assistons les mises en examen 10
dit tarnac. Donc les 10 mises en examen.
Et là la première chose que nous
faisons, c'est que nous confrontons
les informations contenues dans le 204
avec la réalité. Donc on fait des
transports sur les lieux à multiples
reprises et on constate que c'est juste
impossible qu'il y a plein d'éléments
qui sont faux notamment sur la vitesse
parce que si on suit les indications
données par les policiers contenus dans
le procès verbal, il aurait fallu faire
du 169 km/h de moyenne en pleine nuit
sur la route de campagne. C'est juste
impossible. ou alors du 270 km/h si pour
le chemin retour, il se trompe de rues,
il se trompe de nom, il dit sous les
ponts sur les ponts et on se dit tiens,
c'est quand même bizarre, ça ressemble
beaucoup
à un espèce de procès verbal qu'on
rédige via Google Map.
Or Google Map se trompe comme eux.
Google Map, il dit que l'autoroute, elle
passe
sur le pont quand c'est sous le pont ou
inversement.
Et les erreurs de Google Map, on les
retrouve toutes
dans le D4. Sachant que vous avez Julien
Coupa qui vous dit "Moi, j'ai jamais été
près d'une voie ferrée, hein." C'est que
il vous le dit, "Moi, je n'ai jamais été
à cet endroit-là. C'est pas possible."
On lui amène des photos parce qu'à
l'époque, il était sous contrôle
judicière, il avait pas le droit d'aller
en ciném. On lui amène des photos, des
vidéos. Il dit, je ne je suis jamais
allé à cet endroit-là. Et donc, vous
avez des éléments, vous dites "C'est
quand même bizarre
le procès verbal, les éléments physique,
donc c'est pas une interprétation, c'est
des éléments objectifs physiques sont
inconciliables avec la réalité." Donc
c'est faux.
Les fonctionnaires en question qui qui
ont fait des
témoignages ou des procès verbaux entre
guillemets faux, est-ce qu'il y aura des
sanctions contre la police, contre
l'État ? Est-ce que Julien Coupa compte
contreattaquer demander des dommages
intérêt pour
Julien Coupa et les autres sont en droit
de demander réparation du fait de leur
incarcération puisque il a été relaxé
c'est définitif
c'est très faible en France sais on
n'est pas aux États-Unis
combien
je crois que c'est grosso modo si on
fait une moyenne c'est 2000 € par mois
de détention 3000 € à peu près ça les
moyennes
c'est une misère c'est qu'on vous prive
de votre liberté vous êtes enfermé 22h
sur 24 euh sur la base d'éléments qui
sont totalement faux ou ironés et 10 ans
plus tard, quand vous demandez
réparation, on vous donne une pièce.
Ça ça veut dire qu'on peut mettre en
France des innocents en prison
impunément
si c'estes si ces fonctionnaires ne sont
pas sanctionnés.
Bah non, mais moi j'en veux pas au
fonctionnaires de police hein.
Ça c'est c'est un vieux réflexe
français. C'est c'est je pense que comme
vous disiez votre écran c'est une
question internet. Mais moi j'en veux
plus au juge.
Le fonctionnaire de police il a pas de
pouvoir de décision. fonctionnaire de
police, il fait part de sa conviction,
il fait part des éléments. Il dit
"Voilà, moi j'ai ce procès verbal, j'ai
fait ça, j'ai vu ça, libre à vous de
prendre la décision. Fonction de police,
c'est a 100 fois moins de pouvoir qu'un
juge."
Mais le mec qui fait son son sa
déposition avec Google Map là
qui fait son plan euh
lui il vient quoi lui ? On a son nom, on
sait où il habite, Mancheron.
Alors, vous avez le droit de citer son
nom ?
Ah ouais, j'ai le droit. Enfin le le le
dur, on n' pas le droit de révéler
l'identité d'un policier.
Euh mais je ne révèle rien puisque son
nom est connu. Vous tapez Bruno
Mancheron sur Google, vous allez avoir
50 articles, c'est le signateur du D4.
Il en est où ?
[Musique]
Je pense qu'il est encore dans les
services. Il est encore policier. Et et
Julien Coupa, il lui en veut ou pas ?
Non,
non, je crois pas. Je crois pas. Mais
il faut arrêter. Je termine ma ma ma
mon analyse sur le le par rapport à la
question de votre
téléspectateur.
Les plus responsables sont pas les
policiers, c'est pas Bruno Manchon.
Bruno Manchon, il signe un procès
verbal. C'est un procès verbal de
filature, c'est un procès verbal dans
lequel il y a à peu près il y a on a
jamais eu le chiffre précis. Ça aussi
c'est entre 16 et 18 fonctionnaires de
police qui ont participé à une filature,
il signe.
C'est le seul,
tu es le seul qui le signe. Donc il fait
un procès verbal qui n'est pas de
constat mais un simple procès verbal de
renseignement. passage, il oublie de le
préciser. C'est dire que il rapporte des
faits dont il a pas été personnellement
témoin, sachant que il rapporte des
faits, on le sait de par l'enquête, de
par la plainte que nous avons déposé
pour faux que il y a également 12
fonctionnaires de la DCRI qui ont
participé à cette filature et donc alors
eux, on peut même pas les interroger en
frontal et on peut pas avoir leur
identité parce qu'ils sont tous protégés
par le secret de la défense nationale.
Donc c'est-à-dire que quand vous êtes
dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire, vous avez des membres de
la DCRI qui participent alors qu'on
pourra jamais être confronté à eux. Vous
voyez la déloyauté du système et c'est
ce qui a sanctionné également le
tribunal. Mais pour revenir sur le D4,
on constate
en octobre euh tu par notre travail de
contre-enquête en octobre 2009 que c'est
impossible ce que le policier affirme
avoir vu et ce que les policiers
affirment avoir vu parce que là il
précise pas qu'il est tout seul à
l'avoir signe et il dit c'est la police
et la police est toujours soutenue et
s'est toujours présenté comme les
fonctionnaires de police ont le fameux
nous majesté
dit c'est juste pas possible et on le
dénonce
et ça fait l'objet puisque les
journalistes sont très euh agacés dans
ce dossier puisqu'ils ont tous été
roulés dans la farine, ils ont tous été
pris en flagrant délit
de euh relayeur de l'information
policière. que vous êtes vous avez
novembre 2008, ils reprennent sans
aucune retenue toutes les affirmations
policiers. Les seuls qui ne le font pas,
c'est le canard enchaîné
pour changer.
Oui. Non mais non, c'est pire. C'est
quand ils se rendent compte qu'ils ont
été manipulés, qu'ils ont été induités
en erreur et qu'il y a rien, il y a un
retournement de situation. Et donc là,
il y a un très grand nombre de
journalistes qui souhaitent connaître la
vérité. Et pourquoi les policiers ont
affirmé cela ? De plus, vous avez une
défense qui est extrêmement euh bien
organisée du côté euh des mises en
examen puisqueà l'époque, ils étaient
euh mis en examen. Vous avez des
tribunes qui sont publiées, vous avez un
comité de soutien qui est magnifique,
qui est c'est vraiment ce qui a été
monté, c'est c'est fabuleux. Vous avez
Eric Azan qui est vraiment qui qui qui
est éditeur et qui a un rôle
exceptionnel. Et donc lorsque nous
communiquons nos éléments fruits de
notre contre-enquête, lorsque nous
amenons, nous accompagnons un très grand
nombre de journalistes sur place en
disant "Regardez le procès verbal,
regardez la réalité", ça ne ça ne matche
pas, c'est pas possible. Immédiatement,
il y a un retournement de situation.
J'ouvre une parenthèse.
Je vais être très cynique, même si c'est
sale. Si si dans ce dossierlà, ça avait
été trois loulous de banlieu avec des
prénoms exotiques, est-ce qu'il y aurait
eu une un tel soutien médiatique ou un
tel comité de soutien ? Est-ce que
à votre avis,
je pense pas. Je pense pas.
C'est qu'on aurait mis des gamins en
tôle.
En même temps, Julien Coupa est en
prison. Mais je pense mais je pense pas.
Oui, je suis convaincu que ça n'aurait
pas généré une telle mobilisation et ça
n'aurait pas intéressé
autant les journalistes, même le public.
Ce qui ce qui ce qui est intéressant
dans l'affaire dite de Tarnac, c'est
qu'il y a eu une identification
immédiate.
Cette identification, elle s'est faite
pour sur la base de plusieurs facteurs.
C'est que vous avez des jeunes gens pour
certains brillants à minima cultivés qui
s'expriment très bien, qui sont blancs,
qui sont issus de la classe moyenne,
sont pas du tout issus la très haute
bourgeoisie comme on a de cesse de
l'écrire. Je un coup pas, c'est juste le
fils de médecin. Euh ce sont des des des
gens qui vivent très correctement mais
ils sont pas millionnaires ni
milliardaires. Ça c'est c'est justement
des éléments de langage de la police
pour casser l'identification possible.
Ça c'est il y a il y a des services de
com au parquet, il y a des services de
com au sein de la police. C'est le jeu
mais il faut le savoir.
Mais ce sont des jeunes personnes qui
s'expriment bien, qui sont blanches, qui
sont de gauche et qui dénoncent un très
grand nombre enfin un certain nombre de
de de
casse sociale.
Oui. de choses que n'importe quelle
personne sensée approuve.
Et vous avez des journalistes
qui sont exactement du même milieu.
C'est le même milieu. C'est le même
monde. Ceux qu'on 50 ans, bah ça aurait
pu être leurs enfants. Ceux qui ont 25
ans, ça aurait pu être eux.
Et derrière vous avez des gens qui
communiquent extrêmement bien. Et
nous-même, nous avocat, on a énormément
communiqué mais on a repris exactement
les mêmes méthodes. Et donc là, il y a
eu la mise en œuvre d'une bataille, il
une vraie bataille de com qu'ils ont
perdu. Ils ont gagné dans un premier
temps et dans un 2è temps, ils l'ont
totalement perdu parce que la vérité
était de notre côté et parce queil y a
eu une mobilisation de la part des
journalistes et un suivi de la part des
journalistes. Si les journalistes nous
avaient n'avaient pas relayé toutes les
irrégularités que nous ne cessions de
dénoncer, la déloyauté de l'enquête que
nous n'avons une cesse de dénoncer, mais
jamais il y aurait eu de contre-enquête
policière au sein même de l'instruction
puisque le juge d'instruction Thierry
Fragoli a été contraint de demander des
explications
au service de police. Donc les services
de police se sont retrouvés dans la
situation de personnes devant justifier
leurs actes et justifier ce qu'il
faisait. Et ça c'est ce que nous
voulions depuis le début parce queà
partir du moment puisqu'on savait qu'ils
avaient menti, on savait que c'était
faux que le procès verbal des 104
contient des éléments qui sont
totalement faux. Comment voulez-vous
faire apparaître la vérité quand c'est
faux ? Vous le seul moyen de tenter de
sauver le peu qui reste du procès verbal
de 104, c'est de donner d'autres
explications tout aussi fausses. Seul
moyen de sauver un mensonge, c'est d'en
créer un deuxième
plus gros.
Et c'est ce que Nonsesse de dénoncer.
Donc on l'a dénoncé une deuxième fois,
une troisième fois, une 4è fois et la
machine s'est totalement écroulée. Et le
seul moyen qu'ils avaient, c'était de
refuser
très rapidement. Donc c'est la troisème
demande d'acte que nous faisons.
Le seul moyen qu'ils avaient pour
maintenir un semblant de enfin pour pas
que toute l'affaire s'écroule. Donc en
euh euh
ouais janvier, février, mars euh 2010,
c'est de produire ces mensonges. Nous
avons analysé justement cette fameuse
contre-enquête, le fruit de cette
contre-enquête policière et là de
nouveau, nous avons relevé un très très
grand nombre d'irrégularités et de
contre vérité. Et là, il y a eu une
réaction immédiate de la part de
l'instruction, enfin du parquet et des
juges d'instruction, c'est de refuser
systématiquement nos demandes d'acte.
Pour savoir, une demande d'acte pour
pour que vous compreniez quand vous êtes
dans le cadre d'une instruction, donc
quand il y a un juge d'instruction,
c'est lui qui dirige l'enquête. C'est
plus le procureur, c'est le juge
d'instruction, juge indépendant. Donc
vous avez le procureur qui a trop droit
de faire un très grand nombre de
demandes, interroger telle ou telle
personne, faire telle ou telle
perquision, exploiter tel ou tel
ordinateur euh et cetera. Et c'est le
juge qui décide oui ou non. Mais la
défense a aussi ces droits-là. Donc la
défense peut demander, peut solliciter
de la part du juge un très grand nombre
d'investigations afin de vrai à la
manifestation de la vérité et notamment
par exemple disculper les personnes qui
sont mises en examen.
Dans ce dossier, il y a eu 42 demandes
d'acte,
il y a eu 39 refus.
La première demande d'acte qui a été
acceptée, c'est la fameuse
contre-enquête de novembre 2009
puisqu'ils étaient convaincus que en
deux temps trois mouvement de toute
façon ce qu'on affirmait n'allait
aboutir à rien. Ils allaient reconnaître
l'erreur temporaire en disant "Oui, on
peut pas le faire en 10 minutes, c'est
vrai, mais c'est pas grave. On a
confondu 3 et 8, ça c'était leur
première défense, mais ils n'ont pas
compris qu'en rentrant dans cet
engrenage, ils allaient tout perdre et
que tout allait s'effondrer parce que il
y a il y a un système, ça allait générer
d'autres questions. Les réponses
allaient générer d'autres questions qui
allaient générer euh de nouveau euh
d'autres réponses qui allaient générer
d'autres questions. Et donc le seul
moyen c'était de faire des de répondre
par des mensonges. Ce qu'ils ont fait et
donc ils ont immédiatement bloqué et
tout refusé. Et les deux autres demandes
d'acte auquel ils ont fait droit, c'est
des transmissions de pièces d'un dossier
à un autre dossier et tout le reste ils
ont refusé. J'ouvre une une autre
parenthèse. La conduite introspective de
notre système judiciaire ou de de notre
système policier d'investigation, elle
en est où après Tarnac ?
Il y a eu des fonctionnaires promus, pas
promus ? Est-ce que il y a eu des
enquêtes internes ? Est-ce que le juge
d'instruction
pour résumer trivialement les choses,
est-ce que il y en a qui se sont fait un
peu taper sur les doigts comme il faut ?
Je le sais pas, mais d'après les échos
que j'ai, pas du tout.
Il y a juste le juge d'instruction
Thierry Fragoli qui aujourd'hui exerce
Tahiti.
Est-ce que c'est une promotion ou pas
pour nos concitoyens des îles ? J'espère
que oui.
Maintenant euh
je termine sur le D4.
Donc nous démontrons que le D4
ne peut pas être considéré comme un
élément à charge mais au contraire un
élément à décharge. Reste T42.
Donc vous avez deux éléments. Il y a
deux piliers. Le dossier repose sur deux
piliers. Le D4
donc filature du 7 au 8 novembre 2008 et
T42 14 novembre 2008.
On fait tomber le D4 mais il reste T42.
Et là, vous avez un travail qui a été
effectué et je tiens à le saluer. C'est
Tristan qui à l'époque travaillait à
TF1, aujourd'hui travaille dans la
production de cash investigation qui lui
va plus loin.
Bonjour Élise.
Oui, c'est c'est Benah, il travaille
avec Éise Duet et lui fait son travail
de journaliste et lui aussi a la
conviction que c'est bien Jean-Luc
Bourgeois
le témoin anonyme et il va l'interroger
et il le filme
et il le fait parler. il se présente
comme journaliste. C'est très très
important. Et Jean-Huc Bourgeois
explique qu'il en a assez,
que ça suffit l'affaire de Tarnac, que
il a signé ce qu'on lui a demandé de
signer
que
bah les services, les enquêteurs
euh ils n'avaient pas le choix. Mais ils
vous ont menacé. Oui, il m'ont menacé
d'être le 10e parce qu'à l'époque il y
avait neuf personnes qui allaient être
déférées, mis en examen et
certains détenus notamment des jeunes
filles.
C'était pas des affabulations
ce qu'il a dit.
C'est quand même grave.
Alors justement c'est là où c'est
intéressant c'est qu'il dit ça et il est
enregistré, il est filmé.
On peut se dire de toute façon c'est un
mythomane.
Il peut aussi mentir dans les deux sens.
Donc nous quand nous sommes informés
comme des milliers de personnes, des
millions de personnes de l'existence de
cette nouvelle version de Jean-Luc
Bourgeois, première chose que nous
demandons c'est d'être confronté à
Jean-Bourgeois. Vous allez poser une
question très simple. Monsieur, vous
avez dit ça à un journaliste, vous avez
été filmé, c'est enregistré, c'est
diffusé au journal de 20h. Écoutez, moi
j'ai T42 mais j'ai aussi votre audition
de décembre 2009. Quand est-ce que vous
dites la vérité ? Et ben ça on nous le
refuse. Le juge d'instruction,
comment il s'appelle déjà ?
Thierry Fragoli refuse que nous
puissions
qui aujourd'hui
refuse que nous soyons confrontés
avec Jean Bourgeois.
Le parquet refuse.
Pourquoi ? Ils ont peur de quoi ?
Lorsqu'il y a
l'audience qui s'ouvre, nous avons cité
un très grand nombre de témoins, très
grand nombre de personnes dont Jean-Luc
Bourgeois.
Le parquet a le droit et a le pouvoir de
faire citer un certain nombre de
personnes.
Il a fait citer les cinq policiers
membres de la sous-direction
antiterroriste qui soit-disant avait
participé à la filature dans la nuit du
7 au 8 novembre.
Je lui dis moi j'ai pas l'identité
officiellement
de T42. C'est que c'est bourgeois. Je me
moquais je me moquais gentiment du
parquet. C'est moi j'ai fait citer
Jean-Ic Bourgeois. Il serait bon
monsieur le poker que vous fasses citiez
que vous fassiez citer T42.
Et dans l'hypothèse où Jean-Hourgeois ne
vient pas
quand même important que vous demandiez
au service de police ce qu'il soit amené
de force.
Le parquet a jamais voulu que la défense
puisse interroger Bourgeois ou même être
confronté ou même lui poser la moins de
question. Or, l'audience a permis de
prouver quoi ?
que Fabrice Gardon, commissaire de
police, qui était le chef du groupe de
l'antiterrorisme à l'époque
avait
interrogé Jean-Cuc Bourgeois au mois de
décembre 2008 en toute connaissance de
cause en sachant pertinemment
que c'était également T42. Et lorsque la
présidente lui dit "Mais vous vous
rendez compte de la déloyauté, vous
rendez compte que personne n'a accès à
la véritable identité du témoin anonyme
? Le tribunal n'a pas accès à l'identité
d'un témoin anonyme. Seul le JLD a accès
à l'identité du témoin anonyme. On lui
délègue un poir. C'est pour ça qu'on le
déluge de la liberté.
Le juge de la liberté de la détention.
Donc on un juge indépendant du siège. On
le législateur a refusé de conférer ce
pouvoir au procureur parce qu'il dit non
le procureur il est pas indépendant. Le
progur est totalement dépendant et c'est
hiérarchique et il dépend du ministère
de la justice. Et lorsque président tu
dis "Mais vous rendez compte, vous
l'avez fait alors que ce sont deux
versions totalement différentes
La réponse est d'une franchise
extraordinaire, c'est oui. Bon là vous
l'avez vu, ça a pas marché mais ça
aurait pu marcher.
Et c'est là la présidente dit ça aurait
pu marcher. C'estàd que vous aurez pu
induire en erreur tout le monde.
Et donc si nous avons pu
dénoncer cela, c'est grâce à un travail
journalistique et c'est grâce à la
commission d'un délit. que je rappelle
quand même que ce qu'a fait Tristan
était
une infraction, c'était un délit et il
l'a fait en toute connaissance de cause
et bien évidemment, il a pas été
poursuivi
ça aurait été le comble. Mais ce qui est
extraordinaire, c'est que moi
qui euh était en contact avec certains
journalistes de chez TF1 et d'autres
journalistes, ces derniers m'ont appelé
parce qu'il savait que je m'entendais
extrêmement bien avec Tristan et il
savait que j'avais connaissance de ce
qu'allait faire Tristan révéler
l'identité de Jean Bourgeois. Ils m'ont
appelé pour lui mettre la pression, pour
lui rappeler que c'était un délit et que
si jamais
le parquet allait poursuivre et c'est ce
qu'il allait faire, ça allait être très
difficile pour Tristan.
Ils ont été jusqu'au bout et cette
personne qui m'a appelé, donc ce
journaliste m'a confirmé après que
c'était les services qui lui mettaient
également la pression pour que
l'identité de Jean-Courgeois ne sorte
jamais.
Donc on se retrouve juste pour pour
terminer alors je sais que c'est très
long, je m'en excuse mais on se retrouve
dans une situation où au mois de mars
2010 donc nous sommes désignés en
septembre, nous pendant 3 mois nous euh
mettons toutes nos forces à détruire
toute notre énergie à détruire le 104 et
parallèlement à ça on détruit grâce au
travail des journalistes le témoignage
T42. Donc les deux piliers s'écroulent
dans n'importe quel autre pays. Enfin,
considéré vous qualifiez d'état de
droit, Angleterre, États-Unis,
euh Allemagne, Italie, Espagne, à partir
du moment ou Russie, si ça vous fait
plaisir,
Portugal ou
ou Portugal, non mais enfin les les les
Suède, non mais les pays c'est souvent
c'est on compare la la France et pas les
sauvages. Non non la France avec les les
Anglo-Saxons parce que c'est pas c'est
le droit latin et puis
droit romain et le droit
de la de la comm la c'estàd que tout
le droit anglais
dans n'importe quel autre état de droit
on arrête les frais à ce moment-là
soit on annule
soit on fait non lieux en France non
parce que en France ça implique de
déjuger la police, dejuger le parquet et
de déjuger les juges d'instruction
et de les sanctionner.
Non,
justement, c'est ce que c'est c'est
j'avais j'avais perdu le film tout à
l'heure. Moi, j'en veux pas au policier.
Non, mais il faut arrêter quand même.
Non non non non, je suis désolé. Le
policier amène un procès verbal. Dans le
procès verbal, il écrit nulle part que
il a vu Julien Coua poser un fer à béton
sortir de la voiture. Il dit ce qu'il a
vu. Il dit "J'ai vu une voiture, j'ai vu
personne sortir. Moi, je considère que
c'est un élément à décharge. Pour le
juge d'instruction, c'est un élément à
charge. Il l'explique, il l'écrit."
Bah alors le juge,
mais le juge n'a rien parce que en
France les juges ne sont responsables de
rien.
Il met de la crème solaire,
je sais pas. Et le juge en France n'est
jamais sanctionné malgré
des instructions comme celle-ci qui n'a
été qu'une instruction à charge où 90 %
de l'énergie dépensée dans cette affaire
a été faite pour tenter de couvrir
la version initiale. C'est une commande.
C'est le parquet qui a demandé euh
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
euh en mars 2008.
En juillet 2008, euh le parquet et la
procureur de la République relance les
services de l'antitorisme en disant on
en est où ? Parce que je vous ai demandé
d'ouvrir une ququette primaire, vous en
est où ? Donc c'est voilà, c'est une
commande. Maintenant, est-ce que c'est
une machination ? Est-ce que c'est un
complot ? Est-ce que c'est euh pour
faire diversion ? Je le pense pas.
C'est juste des incompétents.
Mais moi, je pense moi je fais partie
des gens euh qui pensent que il y a
beaucoup moins de complots. Il y en a
parce que c'est le propre des services
secrets, hein, d'être secret et d'agir
euh ou de faire porter le chapeau par
d'autres. C'est si c'est c'est c'est
c'est leur raison d'être. Mais euh je
pense que ce qui alimente le plus
en raison d'être, c'est protéger l'État,
hein.
Oui. Oui. Protéger l'État. Mais si euh
il faut agir de manière secrète euh et
de manière illégale euh bah ils le font
et euh ils sont missionnés comme tel.
Mais pour revenir, je je pense que ce
qui alimente le plus la principale cause
euh de des complotistes, enfin ce qui ce
qui peut alimenter leur thèse, euh
c'est une carence d'information de de
propre,
mais je crois que c'est l'orgueil que
ils ne veulent pas accepter l'idée que
un très grand nombre de personnes sont
beaucoup plus incompétents que ils le
sont réellement. C'estàd que on on dit
que c'est un complot de la part des
services de police tel ou tel attentat.
Moi je pense pas. Je pense que c'est
surtout que les services de police sont
assez mauvais.
Alors question d'internet. Peut-on faire
un parallèle avec Antonin Bernanos sur
l'affaire de la voiture incendie du qu
de Valmi dans le sens où c'est aussi le
témoignage le témoignage d'un agent de
la DCI DGSE
qui mène à la condamnation du prévenu.
Alors, il y a un parallèle qui est qui
est très important parce que moi-même
j'ai
vérifier si c'est DGSE parce que DGSE
c'est ni l'autre euh c'est un membre de
euh des renseignements de la police euh
de la préfecture de police euh parce que
moi-même j'ai été j'ai assisté euh une
des personnes dans euh faire dit du qu
Valmi où il a Antonin Bernanos qui a été
condamné. Là où il y a euh une
similitude, c'est que en effet Antonin
Bernanos euh a été condamné euh sur la
base d'un témoignage euh anonyme, enfin
qui bénéficie de la procédure
d'anonymisation. Or, dans une erreur, ça
c'est c'est c'est ce sont des génies.
Euh ils avaient oublié euh de retirer
dans le dossier, ils avaient oublié de
retirer euh le procès verbal euh
contenant l'identité euh de ce fameux
témoin et notamment euh la décision du
du juge de la liberté de la détention
euh de faire bénéficier de la procédure
de l'anonyma à cette personne. Or euh
les personnes qui ont pu consulter le
dossier euh tout au début lors de
l'ouverture de l'information judicière
ont pu constater que en effet c'était un
fonctionnaire de police. Moi là où je
trouve scandaleux cette procédure et on
l'avait dénoncé, je l'avais dénoncé à
l'époque dans le cadre de cette
instruction et à l'audience également,
c'est que le texte précise que pour
bénéficier de cette procédure, il faut
non seulement risquer qu'il y ait une
réelle menace pour son intégrité
physique, la vôtre ou celle de votre
famille, mais également de qu'on ne
puisse pas vous soupçonner par rapport à
remarque que je faisais initialement.
sur la garde de vue d'avoir commis la
moindre infraction. Or, cette personne a
dit qu'elle a participé à la
contremanifestation
et notamment qu'elle a suivi
Antonin Bernanos et d'autres notamment à
l'époque mon client Bryan Morot qui a
été relaxé au passage. Donc c'est juste
pour vous dire
le crédit qu'il faut accorder à ce
témoin
durant le cadre de la
contremanifestation et donc quand ils
ont remonté leur rubau repère et le cas
de Valmi. Le fait de participer à cette
contreanifestation
est une infraction. La preuve, c'est
qu'ils étaient poursuivis pour avoir
participé à une manifestation interdite.
Et donc à partir du moment où c'est même
pas on vous soupçonne de c'est vous
rapportez la preuve que vous avez commis
une infraction, bah vous ne pouviez pas
vous vous ne remplissez pas les
conditions pour bénéficier de cet
anonyme. Après, en ce qui concerne
Antonin Bernano, c véritablement
euh scandaleux et et particulièrement
criticable, c'est que l'identification
s'est faite par des amalgames sur la
base d'exploitation de vidéosurveillance
euh où euh enfin ça emporte la
conviction de personne quoi. C'estàd que
au début les mêmes services de police
avaient dit que c'était bien Antonin
Bernanos qui avait jeté le plot qui a
permis le la pose d'un fumigène dans la
voiture de police puisque cette personne
porte des lunettes. Après quand ils se
sont rendu compte quand on a Bernos
quand ils l'ont arrêté bah il avait pas
de lunettes
lors de la manifestation. Ils disent "Ah
non, finalement c'est pas des lunettes,
c'est des cernes." C'est ça le niveau.
C'est souvent ça le niveau.
Avec tout ça, vous avez encore confiance
dans notre système judiciaire ? Est-ce
que c'est pas une justice de copains,
une justice de caste, une justice de on
se protège un peu quand on fait des
conneries ? Non non non, je pense pas je
pense pas
je crois pas cette idée de de
justice de cast, justice de classe.
C'est c'est pire que ça.
Ça serait facile si c'était ça.
beaucoup d'incompétences,
mais pas seulement de la part des juges,
pas seulement de la part des policiers,
de la part aussi des avocats,
de la part de tout le monde, de de c'est
c'estd que c'est je vous dis les
principales erreurs judiciaires, c'est
pas le fruit d'un complot, c'est le
fruit d'incompétence
pour compte le fait de mettre de la big
data dans la justice
de de spotter
avec un affichage de tout le monde en
utilisant les technologies les plus
poussées pour pouvoir
faire une enquête.
Moi moi je suis un un grand libertaire
donc à partir du moment où on crée des
fichiers, je commence à m'en méfier.
Moi, je pense que euh
c'est extrêmement dangereux. Mais bon là
ce matin, j'ai été retiré ma carte
d'avocat, ma nouvelle carte puisque
maintenant pour accéder au nouveau
palais de justice, il faut une carte
magnétique. Et très très spontanément,
la personne qui qui me donne qui me t ma
nouvelle carte nous dit "De toute façon,
les services de BIG mettent 3 jours pour
l'activer, donc elle ne sera activée que
mercredi." Je dis "Mais service de BIG,
que bien faire BIG ?" Big, il l'a
construit le bâtiment mais c'est tout.
Et il m'explique très naturellement que
bah c'est bugg qui gère l'activation de
nos cartes magnétiques. Sachant que
quand vous accéder maintenant au nouveau
palais, vous badgez tout. Vous badgez
l'entrée, vous badgez quand vous prenez
l'ascenseur, à quel étage vous allez, à
quelle audience vous allez. Donc ça veut
dire queon a confié à BIG
les ficier
que font les avocats ? Que fait tel
avocat ? Il est où ? Il voit qui ? Quoi
? Comment ? C'est
ça ça a choqué personne. On le découvre
comme ça au détour d'une démarche
extrêmement anodine et tout ça bien sûr
au nom de la sécurité de la protection.
Non, mais pour vous dire dans dans
l'affaire Tarnac,
ce qui moi euh
est passionnant et euh ce qui a été
vraiment euh particulièrement
intéressant, c'est la différence entre
euh l'instruction et l'audience.
À partir du moment où vous avez eu c'est
l'instruction, ça nous a permis de
découvrir les limites
euh de la mauvaise foi de certains
magistrats et on se rend compte que bah
il y en a pas des limites hein. C'est
c'est nos limites. C'estàd que moi
j'avais dit au juges instructeurs, j'ai
dis vous êtes extraordinaire,
vous n'avez de cesse de repousser les
limites du néant. C'est c'est
la justice honte de rien.
Moi je pense que si parce que euh là euh
le jugement
de relaxe c'est une énorme condamnation
de l'instruction.
Donc la justice là non seulement à
relaxé
les gens de Tarnac dit Tarnac Julien
Coupa et ses copains,
mais elle a surtout condamné
l'instruction
et l'instruction
c'est-à-dire les juges d'instruction il
eu cinq il y en a eu cinq
dans le titorisme l'élite de l'élite et
le parquet
je parle même pas la condamnation
policière puisque je vous invite à aller
en jugement, c'est extrêmement violent
et mais c'est c'est la preuve que il
arrive à la justice de de reconnaître
certaines de ces erreurs.
Le budget de la justice en France, c'est
combien ?
Je sais pas.
C'est plus ou moins que le budget de
l'écologie ?
Je sais pas.
Ça serait intéressant de sourcer ça sur
Capitain Fact. Une question d'internet
dans cette affaire qui m le plus. On a
peut-être répondu le gouvernement, la
police, les médias, tout le monde ?
Non mais c'est c'est une question qui
est qui est qui est idiote. Euh dans la
question idiote.
Non non mais pourquoi ? parce que c'est
voir le point de vue justement d'une où
on considère qu'il y a des gens qui
décident dès le début qui sont aux
manettes comme votre injection et il est
aux manettes.
Il y a un très grand nombre de personnes
qui mentent pour justifier leurs erreurs
et donc là ce sont des menteurs et
continuent et ils persévèrent et il
génèrent de nouveaux mensonges. Mais je
crois pas qu'à la base Alomarie était
parfaitement informé que le dossier
reposait sur si peu d'éléments.
Si c'était le cas, elle serait pas allé.
Elle serait pas montée au front, elle
avait que des coups à prendre. Elle
aurait pu attendre quelques jours. Elle
est allée faire sa conférence de presse
parce que on lui a dit vous pouvez y
aller. Fait confiance à ses services. Je
vous rappelle quand même qu'à l'époque
son directeur de cabinet c'était Michel
Delpche qui n'est autre que le préfet de
police de Paris aujourd'hui donc l'une
des personnes les plus importantes de
France. Ce sont des gens extrêmement
raisonnables, très intelligents.
Donc
Michel Marie très intelligente.
Comment
Michelarie très intelligent Michelph ?
Donc euh le le camp quand euh on a euh
une personne de cette qualité comme
directeur de cabinet et euh on doit le
solliciter.
C'est un préfet, c'est aussi un
policier. Enfin, il raisonne comme un
policier.
Quand vous avez le chef des services ou
certains chefs de service qui vous
disent "C'est eux, on nous a affirmé que
c'était eux." Bah vous êtes ministre,
vous faites confiance, vous y allez.
Après, ça pose problème quand vous vous
rendez compte qu'il y a la
contre-attaque, qui a la vague, il y a
le retour de flamme qui est très fort.
Et donc, qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Vous allez pas désavouer vos services de
police, vous leur faites confiance. Puis
vous êtes pas seul, vous avez quand même
Jean-Claude Marin qui était le procureur
de la République de Paris en 2008 qui
fait sa conférence de presse. Depuis, il
y a la fameuse conférence de presse, là
où on voit régulièrement François
Mollins faire ses conférences de presse,
mais à l'époque le parquet n'avait pas
une salle spéciale conférence de presse.
C'est la première grosse conférence de
presse. Jean-Claude Marin fait sa
conférence de presse et Jean-Claude
Marin, je vous invite à aller sur
internet he cette conférence à des mots
extrêmement violents. groupe armée euh
la vie humaine euh pas comité invisible
mais cellules invisible
base arrière d'un groupe Paris. Donc
quand vous avez des gens aussi
compétents et on peut pas on peut
critiquer Jean-Claude Marin, mais on
peut pas lui enlever critiquer sa
compétence, je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le premier
procureur de France, c'est la première
avocat général à la Cour de cassation.
Jean-Claude,
il justifie un peu son budget. Non,
peut-être.
Non, moi je pense que il fait je pense
qu'à ce niveau-là, ils font confiance.
C'est des notes qui remontent, ils font
confiance. Ils regardent certains
éléments du dossier, ils font confiance.
Après,
normalement, et c'est toute la
différence avec le système américain,
pourtant je suis critique mais euh on
doit en tirer les conséquences quand il
y a rien. Et le la première personne qui
doit en tirer les conséquences et qui a
le pouvoir et c'est sa mission puisqu'il
doit instruire un charge. Charge, c'est
juste d'instruction. Et là dans cette
affaire, il y a jamais eu de juges
d'instruction. Il y a eu que des
procureurs de la République. Que les
juges d'instruction avaient exactement
la même attitude que le parquet. Et
c'est là où ça déraille complètement. Et
c'est là où ça aboutit à l'affaire dite
de Tarnac où ça aboutit à un tel
désaveux 10 ans plus tard dès qu'on a
une audience publique avec des juges qui
sont indépendants et qui instruisent à
charge et à décharge. Mais normalement
ce dossier s'écroule. Je vais vous faire
euh
avant.
Non non mais je veux juste juste c'est
très important.
Comment on fait pour changer tout ça ?
Regardez regardez la la réforme de
Sarkozy sur la suppression du juge
d'instruction était une très très bonne
réforme. Euh malheureusement elle est
pas passée. Regardez la similitude avec
l'affaire des SK. Vous êtes à New York,
c'est planétaire. Vous avez Vince,
procureur
qui monte au front, qui demande
l'incarcération de DSK parce queil
considère que les témoignages de Tou
Dialo sont crédibles. C'est lui qui le
demande. Il sait les conséquences que ça
va être. Il sait qui est DSK. C'est non
seulement la FMI, mais c'est
potentiellement le futur euh président.
Alors que s'il l'incarcère, ça sera
jamais le président.
Il le fait,
on le laisse faire. Non non, la justice
le suit. C'est pas lui qui a incarcéré
DSK, il l'a demandé. Il a monté un
dossier, il l'a demander. Le juge
incarcère,
le juge libère. On est en mai 2011, si
je dis pas de bêtises.
En août, en août 2011, il a accès à des
informations qui n'ont strictement rien
à voir avec l'affaire DSK. C'est par
l'intermédiaire d'écoutes téléphonique
où il se rend compte que cette
personne-là communique avec une autre
personne et que elle révèle avoir
trafiqué. C'est si je dis pas je parle
sous le contrôle de internautes mais il
y a le rapport qui a été publié sur
traduit et publié sur Mediapart comme
quoi elle son un interlocuteur se
servait de certains de ses comptes
bancaires pour déposer de l'argent ou
faire transiter de l'argent qu'il il
avait amassé via un trafic de
stupéfiant.
Il se révèle qu'elle a plusieurs
téléphones portables alors qu'elle avait
dit au service de police qu'elle avait
qu'un seul téléphone portable. Que fait
Vince ?
Bah il en tire les conséquences. C'est
toute la différence parce que lui il est
responsable. Il en tire les conséquences
où il dit je suis désolé dans ces
conditions la crédibilité
de Naalo, elle est atteinte.
Pour moi, elle vaut plus rien. Donc je
retire tout. C'est lui qui blanchit.
DSK a été mis hors de cause par la
personne qui l'a qui a qui l'a arrêté
qui a demandé son incarcation. Voyez
toute la différence
en France dans l'affaire dit de Tarnac
un juge d'instruction aurait dû dire je
suis désolé les éléments présentés comme
à charge
après exploitation sont doivent être
considérés comme des éléments et la
crédibilité est atteinte. La déloyauté
est extrêmement importante. J'en tire
les conséquences. Non lieu. En France,
on s'obstine. C'est c'est vraiment c'est
c'est très français.
C'est très français de refuser de
déjuger
ses collègues. D'ailleurs, il y a il y a
une vraie réflexion à avoir.
On appelle les magistrats quand on
qualifie des gens de magistrat, c'est
tant les magistrats du parquet que du
siège. Vous avez les procureurs ou les
juges.
Il y a il y a une vraie difficulté pour
eux de les les
de les déjugés, de les sanctionner. Et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut saluer la
décision qui a été rendue par le la 14e
chambre présidée par Cohen Godzman qui a
tiré toutes les conséquences
de de cette audience et de l'analyse du
dossier où c'était
tellement violent, tellement évident
que le parquet a eu la dessence de pas
interjeter appel.
On va on va basculer un peu dans notre
dans notre ère au récent au vu des
récents événements avec les les black
tout ça.
Le fait qu'il y ait à peu près c'est un
peu moins de 200 gamins qui se sont fait
attraper mis dans la NAS qui en est
combien ? Il y en a combien qui ont été
mis en examen ? 3 4 5 mise en examen
zéro puisque il y a eu que des
comparisions immédiates et aux dernières
nouvelles
euh il y a eu des demande de renvoi et
il y a eu des contrôles judiciaires qui
ont été ordonnés par le tribunal.
Ils ils ont 3 semaines pour préparer
leur défense, c'est ça ?
Mais ils sont libres.
C'est c'est normal qu'on puisse attraper
tout le monde d'un coup comme ça ? Ben,
c'est là où se pose il y a une vraie
question qui se pose. C'est à partir du
moment où vous interpellez
200 personnes,
mais j'aimerais bien connaître les
raisons
euh qui ont fondé ces interpellations.
Le code deure bénale nous dit que on
peut placer quelqu'un en garde à vue si
on le soupçonne d'avoir commis une
infraction. Euh, j'aimerais bien
connaître leurs soupçons parce que euh
privé de liberté 200 personnes, c'est
très très grave.
C'est quoi ? C'est une rafle.
Bah, je vous renvoie la définition d'une
rafle, mais euh là, on a quand même euh
l'impression qu'ils ont été arrêtés euh
sur des motifs qui me paraît des plus
critiquables. Alors, je les connais pas,
j'ai pas eu les 200 mais à mon avis,
c'est d'avoir été à tel endroit, à tel
moment
du ramassage scolaire.
Je sais pas mais c'est grave.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Il y a aucun blessé grave.
Il y a eu aucune arme qui a été
utilisée. Je sais pas arme explosive,
arme à feu.
Cocktail monotof. Non, pas du tout. Des
pavés,
j'ai pas eu l'impression. Je crois qu'il
y a eu des mises à feu mais c'est pas
via des cocktail. Raf l'opération
politicière exécuté à l'improviste dans
des lieux dans un lieu suspect en vue
d'appréhender les personnes qui s'y
trouvent et de vérifier leurs identités.
Non, je je pense pas que ça soit cette
définition en droit et en plus il y a
une connotation euh qui nous renvoie à
l'occupation où c'est en fonction d'un
groupe enfin de votre appartenance à un
groupe ethnique ou religieux. Mais euh
je tiens quand même à rappeler une chose
euh nous sommes en 2018, il y a pas
d'armes qui ont été utilisées. Il y a
pas de policiers qui ont été victimes
d'armes à feu ou de cocktail motof. Il y
a pas eu de risque de débordement
extrêmement violent puisque les
journalistes ont tous pu filmer. Euh
même les passants pouvaient tous filmer.
Mais j'ai même vu que les euh les
personnes qui étaient à l'intérieur du
McDonald's se filment pendant l'attaque
ou filmait l'attaque.
Euh nous sommes en période de paix
civil. Est-ce qu'on n pas encore en
guerre civile ni en guerre sociale ?
Pourquoi pas encore ?
Je sais pas. En tout cas c'est pas le
cas quoi.
Est-ce que ça sent le sapin ? J'ai pas
l'impression
euh j'ai pas l'impression quand vous
voyez le peu de personnes qui
manifestent euh j'ai pas l'impression
que euh
on soit dans euh ben peut-être hein je
suis j'ai pas assez de compétences ni de
connaissance mais toujours est-il que
dans ce cadre là les 200 personnes qui
sont arrêtées
à qui on ne reproche absolument rien
quelques heures plus tard quelques
dizaines d'heures plus tard on On leur
reproche rien parce que elles ne sont
pas remises en liberté avec un rappel à
la loi et cetera. Non, on les a juste
fiché parce que pour être placé en garde
à vue, donc ils ont pris on a dû prendre
leur emprunte digitale, ils ont dû en
profiter pour prendre le politique
comment. Ouais, je pense qu'ils ont dû
prendre
le leur leur profil gétique. Bien sûr,
ils vont s'engager à le détruire.
On verra un camp. Euh et donc imaginez
en période de guerre.
Et c'est là où j'ai toujours en mémoire
le
la gestion du service d'ordre et
finalement on nous dit
sans arrêt qu'il y a beaucoup plus de
liberté aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait
avant.
J'ai pas j'ai pas cette impression.
J'ai pas cette impression parce que
quand on regarde les mouvements par
exemple anticolonialistes ou de
décolonisation notamment pendant la
guerre d'Algérie,
j'ai pas souvenir qu'il y avait des des
des systématiquement à la moindre
manifestation ou à la moindre vitrine
cassée 200 personnes arrêtées.
Je sais pas je je c'est et on est en
période de guerre où là il y a des
attentats quotidiens
où il y a une véritable lutte armée. une
armée d'ailleurs. Le FLN était une
armée.
Comment vous expliquez cette tension et
cette montée en puissance de la police
en France ?
C'est pas la police qui monte en
puissance, c'est plutôt les les c'est
c'est du c'est une justice spectacle, un
peu comme d'un parnac
que il y a vous avez vu que le premier
ministre et le ministre étaient allé
féliciter les policiers au commissariat
du 13e arrondissement de Paris. Bon ben
voilà, il y a des images spectaculaires,
il faut des réponses spectaculaires.
Spectaculaires 200 d'arrestation quand
même
l'un dans l'autre quoi.
Vous avez je sais pas moi, vous avez 150
policiers qui euh investissent un
village de quelques centaines
d'habitants arnaqu avec des caméras, des
hélicoptères. Bon bah, il faut bien que
ça aboutisse à des arrestations et à des
mises en examen. Combien ça coûté cette
histoire là s'amuser à faire des petits
tours d'hélicoptère pour aller attraper
trois éleveurs de chèvre ? Je pense
plusieurs millions d'euros. Moi
ça va, on m'avait on m'avait donné ce
chiffre, on m'avait dit que ça avait
coûté 8 millions d'euros l'enquête. Ça
m'étonnerait pas pour vous dire en 2011,
il y a le transport sur les lieux. Ils
ont bloqué tout le secteur
que
les avocats,
on était pas nombreux.
Nous étions escortés par 25 véhicules de
gendarmerie.
Ça coûte une fortune.
Quoi ? Pourquoi 25 ? Mais
je sais pas. Je sais pas quoi. Pourquoi
autant ? Pour donner un peu
d'importance, c'est aucun journaliste
n'avait le droit d'approcher le site. Il
y avait un hélicoptère de nuit. C'était
contexte. Mais ça mais tout ça ça
contribue, ça participe au spectacle.
Est-ce que vous est-ce que
donc ça donne de l'importance et donc de
la crédibilité
C'est pas parce que quand même il y a il
y a une mouvance d'extrême gauche ou
d'ultra gauche larvée, dormmente, prête
à se réveiller
et est-ce que ça témoigne pas quand même
de d'acquisition de renseignement de
terrain correctement ? Est-ce que ça
peut être envisageable que les services
de renseignement fassent quand même un
minimum leur boulot correctement et et
voit une émergence
larvée de de de mouvement d'extrême
gauche ou d'extrême droite vraiment
agressif face à des à des fondamentaux
sociétaux. Je vais pas parler de quelque
chose que je connais pas. C'estàd que je
je je pas d'avis sur l'existence ou non
euh
d'un mouvement d'extrême gauche. Ce que
ce dont je peux parler, c'est les
dossiers dans lequel je suis intervenu.
Je vous rappelle que la circulaire d'Ati
en 2008
demandait
au procureur de la République d'ouvrir
des enquêtes ou des instructions pour
terrorisme vis-à-vis des personnes qui
mettaient de la colle dans les
distributeurs et qui mettaient des
slogans anticapitalistes ou antibanqu.
Je vous rappelle que
c'est un signal faible.
Enfin, c'est un signal faible. Si ça
c'est du terrorisme, qu'est-ce qui n'en
est pas ? Et vous faites quoi de
quelqu'un qui va dans une salle de
spectacle ? CAS c'estàd que les les les
la qualification juridique est censée
avoir un sens.
Les budgets sont mal alloués,
c'est-à-dire que on essaie de de de
filer des des des mecs qui mettent de la
de la colle dans les distributeurs alors
que il y a des mecs qui rentrent avec
des calaches.
Non non moi je pense non mais j'ai pas
d'amis. Euh je me permettrai pas de de
de
parler choses que je connais pas. Ce que
je sais c'est que ce qui a toujours été
présenté comme l'avant-garde de
l'extrême gauche, de l'ultra gauche,
fameux révolutionnaire
d'extrême gauche, ben on est très très
loin d'action directe, mais très très
loin. On est très loin du FPLP, on est
très loin
des brigades rouges, on est très loin de
la bande à Badaire mais très très loin.
C'est c'est récemment, vous avez eu quoi
ces dernières années ? une affaire de
dépanneuse. C'estd que il y aurait des
jeunes qui ont été interpellés avec un
fumigène et donc c'est un incendiaire en
effet donc ça peut être qualifié comme
une arme. Vous allez dans n'importe quel
stade de foot. Regardez hier à Marseille
des fumis en avaient partout. On peut
pas considérer qu'il y a eu des
attentats hier à Marseille. Enfin c'est
c'est donc moi moi j'y crois pas.
J'y crois pas puisque euh sinon on
l'aurait vu. Je je crois pas qu'en 10
ans, il y ait eu une personne qui était
victime
euh qui sont mortes
euh par un membre ou au nom de l'extrême
gauche, de l'ultra gauche, vous appelez
ça comme vous voulez. Non, je vois pas.
Ce que je vois, c'est que euh ces 10
dernières années, il y a eu de nombreux
policiers, pour pas dire des dizaines,
qui ont été affectés
euh à ce
ce service, enfin à à enquêter sur ces
personnes-là, notamment à couvrir le
travail euh et à tenter de sauver
l'affaire d' Tarnac, notamment de 2008 à
2012, puisque c'était vraiment le moment
le plus intense dans l'affaire d'Otar
Tarnac où il y avait beaucoup de
policiers qui travaillaient sur ce
dossier et je crois qu'ils auraient été
bien mieux affectés à travailler sur
d'autres euh enquêtes parce que je vous
rappelle quand même que le premier
réflexe euh des responsables de la DCRI,
pour pas dire le responsable de la DCRI
euh en 2012 euh à la suite du euh des
crimes commis par euh Mohamed Mera a été
dire nous sommes en sous-effectif.
C'est sûr que si
vous concentrez toutes vos forces sur un
ennemi imaginaire, bah quand il y en a
un, bah ouais, c'est plus facile pour
lui. Je sais pas, moi je j'ai pas
d'avis, mais je je je fais le lien.
Je me dis que
avec le recul, c'est c'est juste
c'est pas seulement une faute de une
erreur de jugement,
c'est extrêmement grave.
C'està dire que vous rendez compte, on
est en plein procès
tarnac,
on parle de terrorisme parce que bon,
ils ont dû abandonner la qualification
inextrémisme mais le parquet allit
jusqu'à la Cour de Cassation, on a dit
que c'était du terrorisme, du
terrorisme, du terrorisme, du
terrorisme.
Entre-temps, vous avez eu Mera Charlie
Hebdo le 13 novembre et je parle même
pas des autres, les Champs-Élysées, le
le même pendant le procès tarnac qu'il y
a eu le gendarme Beltram. C'estàd que
vous dites "Mais vous
vous êtes où ? Vous êtes où ? Vous êtes
sur quelle planète ?" Et l'élément
présenté comme à charge à partir du
moment où on a pulvérisé le D4 que euh
le euh T42 s'est complètement retourné
sur eux, c'est l'insurrection qui vient.
C'est un livre.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous pensez pas
que le pouvoir politique
pour dire trivialement les choses,
flique les la mouvance d'extrême gauche
? Parce que la mouvance d'extrême
d'extrême gauche s'attaque au
capitalisme, c'est-à-dire au rouage même
de notre société. Alors que le
terrorisme dit islamiste ne s'attaque
que
à un aspect culturel
de notre société.
Je suis pas d'accord avec vous parce
qu'il flique tout le monde, enfin il
fiche tout le monde
et
que c'est c'est c'est quand même ass
c'est impressionnant hein le nombre de
personnes qui sont fichées. Euh je suis
sûr que vous vous avez une fiche hein.
Ah bah nous nous on a des fiches que le
bras nous. Oui, oui, mais mais euh
on leur passe un coucou au moustachu et
aux grandes oreilles.
Comment ça va ? Vous avez pas autre
chose à [__] d'ailleurs ?
C'est c'est euh
je crois qui qui qui fiche beaucoup de
monde. Ouais,
surtout toi là. Bah, rigole pas,
il fiche il fiche il fich font du
ramassage scolaire.
jusqu'au jour où on vous reproche
quelque chose, vous savez,
jusqu'au jour jusqu'au jour où on va
avoir un pouvoir dictatorial qui va se
durcir parce que les fondamentaux
économiques vont partir un peu en
sucette et que le Kaiser qu'on aura mis
à notre tête va devenir un peu
fâché. Excusez-moi de cet aparté plus.
Non, non, mais ça c'est c'est c'est ça
n'engage que vous, c'est votre opinion.
Moi, moi ce que je constate euh c'est
euh
que euh tant que vous êtes fichier qui
vous arrive rien et qu'on ne vous
reproche rien officiellement, bah c'est
quasi indolore. Enfin, sauf si vous
passez un certain nombre de frontières
ou si vous voulez travailler avec
certaines personnes où là les les les
fiches circulent mais dès qu'on vous le
reproche, ça devient un élément à charge
alors que vous n'avez aucun élément pour
vous défendre parce que qui vous fiche
prenez les fichiers S, c'est juste
magique.
C'est quoi les critères pour être
fichier S ?
penseur de gauche peut-être
de gauche ou d'être considéré comme un
islamiste parce que vous allez très
régulièrement à la mosquée parce que
vous pouvez avoir un discours
assez lucide sur des questions
géopolitiques et donc vous êtes
immédiatement fiché s
quand j'entends que certains
responsables politiques veulent à titre
préventif euh incarcérer
euh euh les fichiers S, ils assument
pltement de déléguer le pouvoir
de priver de liberté un individu. Donc
le pouvoir qu'on ne confère qu'au juge
et pas n'importe quel juge, il faut
qu'il soit indépendant, faut qu'il donne
un certain nombre de garanties. Bah, ils
sont prêts à à à le déléguer à n'importe
quel fonctionnaire de police.
C'est un concept. Mais c'est dans ces
cas-là, on n plus du tout dans le même
système juridique et on l'a déjà vu he
dans le passé. On est dans une dictature
là, une prédictature.
Ça dépend ce que vous c'est quoi vos
références.
Je pense pas. On peut pas dire que c'est
c'est dans la conscient collectif quand
même une dictature, c'est que vous êtes
pas libre de
soft dictature. Alors
je sais pas, je sais pas, j'ai pas mais
enfin dans l'inconscient collectif d'une
dictature par exemple cette émission
n'existerait pas. Vous pouvez pas avoir
un tel pouvoir de critique la police.
Par contre, après oui, il y a des dogmes
dans cette société. Il y a il y a a y a
un certain nombre de choses que vous
pouvez pas remettre en cause. Euh
vous connaissez notre chaîne YouTube ?
Votre chaîne ?
Notre chaîne ?
Ouais. Syerview là. Ouais.
Vous avez vu deux trois émissions ou pas
?
Ouais.
Lesquelles ? Euh j'ai vu clin euh Kenne
Klin que j'aime bien. Euh j'ai vu celle
de mon confrère là David Kouby. J'ai
votre avocat. On lui passe le bonjour
d'ailleurs.
J'ai vu euh j'en ai vu pas mal. Euh j'ai
vu en scène, j'ai vu le numéro 2 de
l'ambassade de Russie.
H j'ai vu euh bah mon confrère là Franco
aussi euh
la Pablo Sévigne. Ça ça
Servigne autant pour moi.
Euh
on arrive à la fin de notre émission. On
a pour euh alors on n pas pu tout
traiter et même dans ce format où où on
laisse le champ libre. Euh à la fin,
vous connaissez donc la la dernière
question qui est laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, une bouteille à
la mer,
un livre, quelque chose. Si vous avez
des
a parlé beaucoup de justice,
euh
il y a un livre qui est merveilleux,
extraordinaire euh qui a été écrit par
un romancier allemand au siècle dernier,
c'est Jacob Wisserman. C'est la Fire
Mauritius
et c'est un livre qui est vraiment
extraordinaire puisqu'il
c'est le rapport entre un père enfin
entre un fils et son père où le père qui
est le premier ééquivalent le plus grand
procureur
d'Allemagne
avait son fait de gloire au début et qui
d'une intégrité mais absolue c'est
d'avoir avoir obtenu la condamnation de
Mauritius et son fils par des filles
pour tuer le père, pour prendre des
termes psychanalyse,
va euh faire la contre-enquête et va lui
tenter de réhabiliter enfin
d'innocenter, de réhabiliter Mauritius.
Et c'est fantastique parce que c'est un
livre qui vous euh dit à quel point il
est difficile de juger et qu'il faut
toujours être dans la nuance.
et qu'il faut jamais euh enfin
c'est c'est
beaucoup plus la la vie est bien plus
subtile qu'on peut le croire. C'est pour
ça que je réponds par rapport j'ai
peut-être un peu trop dur quand j'ai dit
que la question était idiote. C'estd que
c'est jamais tout n'est jamais binaire.
C'est beaucoup plus nuancé, beaucoup
plus compliqué
et beaucoup plus difficile. Et donc ce
livre est vraiment merveilleux et pour
c'est l'une l'un des plus beaux livres
sur
la justice, la détention puisque il y a
des pages magnifiques sur qu'est-ce que
la détention, la privation de liberté et
le doute parce que le doute il est de
côté. Ça c'est euh le conseil que je
donnerai pour ceux qui s'intéressent sur
la justice.
Le 2e livre que euh je conseillerai
puisque je sais que vous aimez beaucoup
ça parce que vous êtes assez proche des
services euh c'est vous-même vous me
l'avez dit.
Il a rien dit du tout.
Euh non, je vous taquine. C'est un livre
de Yan Valtin qui s'appelle Sans Patrini
Frontière euh qui euh été écrit juste
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale où
c'est une personne qui a participé à
tous les combats euh révolutionnaires,
qui a participé à la révolution russe et
à au Comit. que l'idée était de la
propager et qui montre euh le danger qui
peut y avoir euh à la mise en œuvre et
au respect d'un très grand nombre de
dogmes et que souvent les personnes et
notamment puisque c'est un allemand euh
il a donc œuvré, c'est quelqu'un qui
aussi était au-dessus de tout soupçon et
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'il
explique à quel point il devait il
recevait les ordres de tuer ou de
liquider un certain nombre de personnes
ou de casser des mouvements euh
révolutionnaires ou de tuer ses
compagnons d'armes parce que c'était un
ordre du parti et parce qu'ils étaient
qualifiés comme contre révolutionnaires.
Et ce qui est vraiment
extraordinaire dans ce livre, c'est que
ça rappelle que ces gens-là sont de
bonne foi.
Si, ils sont de bonne foi, ils pensent
vraiment que c'est pour euh ils le font
au nom de la révolution et pour euh le
parti. C'est un peu comme un militaire.
le militaire quand on lui demande de
faire telle ou telle opération, même si
euh physiquement et concrètement à son
niveau euh c'est plus que critiquable,
je suis convaincu euh qu'il est
convaincu d'agir pour euh le
il le truc qui s'appelle le devoir de
retrait. Non, c'est pas ça.
Oui, mais après vous avez aussi la
conviction enfin la la le crédit que
vous accordez à vos supérieurs
hiérarchiques. Et si on vous dit d'un et
c'est le propre des services d'ailleurs
de faire telle ou telle action même si
elle est manifestement illégale, si on
vous dit qu'il y a ça vous dépasse mais
que vous faites partie, vous êtes un
pion.
C'est la centrale qui décide. La
centrale a toujours raison, c'est ça.
Non, non, mais non, c'est pas ça. Non,
non, je dis pas que la centrale a raison
ou pas.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est la nuance.
C'est une fois de plus, c'est de voir
que ces gens-là sont de bonne foi. C'est
pas des des méchances sanguinaires. Et
c'est Yan Valtin qui a écrit ce livre.
Il était du côté stalinien, mais je suis
sûr que de d'autres côtés, ils étaient
aussi de bonne foi. Vous avez des
membres de de militaires français
pendant la guerre d'Algérie qui étaient
convaincus d'être de bonne foi ou
dogmatique.
Ouais. Enfin pour euh Yan Valtin, c'est
petite parenthèse euh on n'est pas
proche des services, c'est eux qui sont
proches de nous surveillent bien.
C'est prétentieux.
Non non, c'est sûrement réaliste. Euh
Jérémy Assous, merci,
je vous en prie.
Coupz.
[Musique]